yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
I really enjoyed Disney's new
live-action version of their animated
classic The Jungle Book so I wanted to
look back of my top five moments from
the movie before I kick off I've got an
awesome giveaway from our friends at
Genki gear so if you'd like the chance
to win a cool t-shirt like the one I'm
wearing from Genki gears new limited
release range make sure you subscribe
and comments about your favorite moment
from the movie on this video for more
details and ways to enter the comp check
out the gleam link in the video
description below
obviously if you haven't seen the jungle
book yet there are spoilers ahead but
you can always watch my non-spoiler
review the movie right here kicking off
at number 5 is Mowgli's meeting with
King Louie the man-cub is kidnapped by a
pack of monkeys who take him to their
leader who's played like a mob boss by
actor Christopher Walken I love the fact
that at first we only see a bit of King
Louie as he talks to Mowgli from the
shadows it really makes the reveal of
what an absolute beast of an ape ears
more effective this Gigantopithecus is
desperate for Mowgli to give him the
secret of fire or man's red flower as he
calls it cure a few verses while want to
be like you before Baloo interrupts to
try and rescue Mowgli
Baloo's over-the-top talk about how big
a fan ears of King Louie is really funny
then Mowgli makes a run for it and
balloon Bagheera battle a bunch of
monkeys while the King Kong like Louis
chases the man-cub through the stone
temple which soon comes crashing down
around him
pretty dramatic stir at number four is
the movies big action-packed finale when
Bagheera confirms that sheer corners
killed Mowgli's adopted Wolf's father
akela the man-cub runs off to the
village where he grabs the flaming torch
before racing back into the jungle which
he accidentally sets on fire but the
jungle fire is only one of Mowgli's
problems
shere Khan's also ready to take him down
once and for all but Mowgli animal
friends step up and confront a
terrifying tiger in a series of clashes
I like the fact that meanwhile Mowgli's
following Bagheera's advice and using
his human skills to set a trap to bring
down Shere Khan
and after the tiger chases Mowgli into
the blazing jungle and up a dead tree
it's not long before sheer : exits this
world the same way many a Disney villain
has bitten the dust over the years
hands Gruber style and I've got to say I
much prefer the way they
movie ends with Mowgli staying in the
jungle with his friends and family
rather than chasing after a girl as he
does in the 1967 animated film I really
love the movies closing credits which
make it onto my list at number 3 they
start up with the Jungle Book novel
jumping about then it's flung open to
reveal the ruins of King Larry's temple
a gigantic orangutan burst out singing I
want to be like you which continues as
the pages of the book turn and we see
the other animals including Bagheera
Baloo and Shere Khan pop about the pages
and all the photorealistic glory then
they appear as beautiful hand-drawn
style pictures alongside their voice
actors names and then it's back to photo
real creatures including turtles
crawling across the pages of The Jungle
Book and we also get to hear Scarlett
Johansson's hypnotic version of trust in
me car song from the 1967 movie which I
really wish that included in her part of
the movie and there's also a cool
version of bernessa thirties by dr. John
and the night tripperz the credits
really are an absolute imaginative
delight at number two is Mowgli first
faceoff with Shere Khan following the
Tigers threats Bagheera accompanies the
man-cub on his journey to leave the
jungle despite the initial quiet for the
grass on their crossing Bagheera warns
Mowgli to run to the ravine of these
senses something's not right
cue Shere Khan leaping out of the gently
swaying grass and tackling Bagheera
before chasing Mowgli through the field
which is now full of stampeding Buffalo
who race into the muddy ravine where
Mowgli is hurtling to Ward's off
favorite man-cub Shere Khan watches from
above at the edge of the ravine as
Mowgli escaped by grabbing onto the
horns of one of the Buffalo rushing
biomes the scenes really fast-paced and
immersive so much so that you can almost
feel the murders it flies everywhere
including onto the camera lens and that
number one is Baloo's endless quest for
honey
after the lazybones birthdays Mowgli
from car he steps the young humans and
walk up to pay off his debt for being
rescued by shimmying up a huge rock face
to collect honey from the bee hives at
the top it's funny hearing Baloo ashore
Mowgli these particular bees don't sting
it's even funnier when our lovable Liars
joined by a bunch of other animals who
comment on how movies doing and we find
out the bullies tried this many times
before with many monkeys you all
skedaddled as soon as they were stung oh
and when a hue
piece of honey falls on Fred's a pygmy
hog it's so funny when Baloo picks him
up and licks the honey off his back
later Mosely makes himself a protective
suit of leaves and tools to do the job
more efficiently while Baloo lies back
scratching his belly until it's time to
put into action Mobley's and genius new
honey gathering technique then Baloo
goes back to a lazy day floating down
the river singing bernessa 30 while
Mowgli sits on his tongue
okay waiting your favorite moments from
The Jungle Book and how do you think it
compares to the original animation I'm
looking forward to hearing your comments
below if you enjoyed this video you
might want to check out my other jungle
book videos with all the Easter eggs and
references in the movie and also my full
movie review click either the links here
to check those out and don't forget to
subscribe and comment on this video for
a chance to win a cool game keiki a
t-shirt thanks for watching and see you
next time you'll be going where we love
us